hey youtubers it's Charlie so huge news
you probably heard Katee Sackhoff from
Battlestar Galactica and a whole bunch
of other stuff is going to be playing a
huge comic-book character on the flash
this season and because it's been a
little while since I've done a flash
video there's a new brand of the flash
ring giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video they confirm she's
coming to episode 5 the first half of
the season may be coming back during the
second half but it's also going to be an
arrow crossover episode so it's actually
like really big so it makes sense that
they would get a really big guest
actress to play a really big character
if they tease that there would be some
iris West Bachelorette stuff happening
so we don't know how Barry is going to
be involved with the episode we really
only know a couple pieces so it's gonna
be a lot of big stuff happening but it
does imply that Barry and iris will have
some sort of wedding before the end of
the season but that kind of feels like
something they would push to the finale
she had posted this picture to social
media we could go like oh you know
excited for my next project I need to
start getting ready but she blacked out
some of the information so unless you
zoomed in you couldn't really tell what
was going on but there was a flash logo
at the top with the lightning bolt so
people like holy crap she's coming to
the flash this is gonna be awesome so
because she's a pretty notable actress
there was a big question about who she
was gonna play because it would have had
to have been a pretty big character then
just this week they confirmed that she
was going to be playing blacksmith and
if you don't know who that character is
she actually appears during a big
thinker arc in the comics that starts
with something called crossfire earlier
this year when they dropped that the
thinker was going to be coming to the
flash eventually I did a video sort of
explaining his big Wally West arc in the
comics really like the biggest story
that he's ever had in the flash comics
was done by Geoff Johns
while Wally West was still the main
version of the flash before Barry Allen
came back during rebirth so when I talk
about the thinker arc that winds up
turning into a matrix movie type story
that's part of the larger arc that
blacksmith pops up during but she's one
of the newer Rogues she's sort of in
charge of this underground black-market
rogue Network called the network I know
very imaginative but you have to imagine
that there are tons and tons of flash
rogues they have all kinds of backroom
dealings they trade and
goods there has to be a market for that
so it's relatively mid wally west run so
the crossfire story as the name implies
puts wally west in this big crossroads
where he has central city and keystone
city across the bay from each other the
thinker starts to take over keystone
city with this techno virus of his and
then the new rogues led by blacksmith
and a couple other people start to take
over central city
so wally west has this big choice to
make do i try and save central city or
do i start to save keystone city because
he can't do both at the same time
because during this run there's only one
version of the flash available so he's
only one person it's not like he has a
whole big gallery of flash family to
help him out but at the culmination of
that story after he's able to save both
cities he builds that big bridge from
keystone city to central city sort of
uniting them so that was before barry
allen ever came back so of course it
makes sense that if Katee Sackhoff is
going to be playing a really big comic
book villain a rogue that it'd be one
that's tied to the big villain of flash
season 4 the thinker so it sounds like
they had their big list of rogues like
ok the thinker's gonna be our big
villain this season which other rogues
popped up during that run and which of
them are big enough to merit her because
she's not gonna play some small one-off
character but her powers are actually
really freakin cool so she can
genetically manipulate things she's a
techno path and she's a genius with
crazy amounts of money so for instance
you see this image here of her in her
like full comic book costume she forms
this from metal in technology around her
so in the way that cyborg can control
technology remotely and interface with
things she can do that too so she's a
badass in her own right and a bit of a
team leader so i wouldn't be surprised
if like you know mirror master was the
leader of the Rogues last season i
wouldn't be surprised if she becomes the
new leader of whatever new rogues team
happens during this season but the team
that she forms is actually mere master
weather wizard trickster magenta Gurdurr
plunder in murmur we actually met a
couple of those newer rogues last season
so weather wizard has still been around
he's sort of floating off in the wind he
could always come back same thing for
trickster I think
Kamel will probably always be the main
version of trickster on the flash TV
show and because of his Star Wars
filming schedule he tends to be a
one-off thing so I don't think the
trickster is gonna be part of this new
rogue steam magenta we met last season
girder hasn't been around in a while he
was the one that wound up being the
undead zombie during season two so we'll
see what they do with him I'm not
expecting him to come back but murmur
you may remember from arrow seasons 3 &
4 so I don't think that he's gonna be
back either he is a pretty freaky story
and I think they're trying to go with
more of a season 1 vibe so actually a
really good thing to do just to get a
sense for the feel of season 4 is to go
back and re-watch some of your favorite
season 1 episodes because they said that
they're kind of going back to season 1
the same way that arrow kind of went
back to arrow season 1 during season 5
almost like the writers on both the
shows are like oh we got a little off
base before we're gonna try and
recapture some of that magic that we
started out with with some really cool
new characters including Starbuck from
Battlestar Galactica the really cool
thing about this new team of rogues
led by blacksmith is that they have
almost nothing to do with what the
thinker's plans are the thinker has his
own ideas for what he wants to do he
wants to expand his consciousness the
flash is a big part of that the fastest
man alive
against the fastest mind alive so I
don't think we're gonna see any
blacksmith vs. thinker episodes we had
that episode where Captain Cold was
fighting with mirror master it was sort
of like a rogue war they might have a
couple moments like that this season
because even though Katee Sackhoff has
only announced for this one episode the
first half of the season
I'm really hoping she returns in the
back half of the season because she
sounds like she's gonna be a big enough
character that she'll escape the flash
and just continue to do whatever else in
the background
you always have to imagine the
characters like gorilla grodd characters
that are so big that you're not going to
be able to contain them they're too
dangerous you do set to chase them out
of town with their tail between their
legs until they can build their
resources and come back in full force
speaking of which we talked about it
before but Gorilla Grodd is actually
gonna be one of the big villains on
legends of tomorrow season 3 they did
not say what the name of the big evil
team-up is going to be but Marc
Guggenheim was teasing that he does have
a name
so it could be a secret society it could
be in Justice Society we'll find out
more about that as we get closer to the
premiere and even though they haven't
been talking about it a lot recently
Titans is still getting ready to shoot
its first episode in September I think
it's September October really soon they
haven't announced who's playing
Nightwing they've really only said who
they're Raven is like that's all we know
she's gonna be young Beast Boy will be
young Starfire and Nightwing are gonna
be the older characters they'll be like
Oliver Queen age you know like late 20s
early 30s so just be prepared for some
information about Titans to drop really
soon there'll be some new trailers for
flash arrow all the rest of the DC shows
pretty soon - they're still cooking
along on the big crossover episode I did
a video about that last week what'll
happen is is I'll name the giveaway
winner when I post my next DC video
there's a bunch of comic book stuff
happening but there's also the Game of
Thrones finale and Rick and Morty
happening right now so if you're not
sure which videos I'm posting just go to
my videos tab that's like the best way
to see what the last week of videos has
been once we get through Game of Thrones
there'll be a little bit more comic book
stuff happening so I'm gonna do some
more defenders more DC stuff later this
week while you wait for everything you
can click here to learn more about that
thinker arc from the comics and you can
click here for the trailer for the Game
of Thrones finale thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight